[Música]
y que sintieron la última vez que
crearon una obra de arte un
emprendimiento quizá un servicio o una
receta
crear nos emociona no se empodera nos
sorprende y puede darle significado a la
vida
mientras creamos no importa si tenemos
títulos no importa la experticia lo que
importa es el fluir y la magia
ya lo decía el psiquiatra donald
winnicott crear nos da la sensación de
que la existencia real y tiene sentido
sin embargo si en este momento les
pidiera que tomaran papel y lápiz
escribieran un poema y se levantarán a
declamarlo varias voces vendrían a sus
mentes para salvarlos de crear no no lo
siento yo nunca fui bueno con las
palabras poesía eso no es para mí eso es
para gente con ciertas sensibilidades
a mí no me gusta expresar mis emociones
en público
todos los días nos enfrentamos a lo
desconocido creamos nuevas rutas nos
entusiasmamos con los comienzos y
soñamos con futuros geniales pero cuando
nos preguntan si somos creativos decimos
no o por lo menos no tan creativos como
esos espíritus libres como esos
inventores o transformadores sociales
y cuando tenemos la oportunidad de crear
aparecen en nuestra mente prejuicios
voces de figuras de autoridad e incluso
recuerdos dolorosos que nos dicen es
mejor quedarse donde estamos y no
avanzar
a estos obstáculos interiores se le
suman
las costumbres de la sociedad y la más
importante es celebrar las obras
terminadas sino el proceso valoramos el
cuadro maravilloso o el emprendimiento
exitoso pero muy poco se habla de las
largas marchas
de los desiertos de los días grises de
las motivaciones más hondas de los
milagros y sobre todo de cómo el proceso
va transformando al creativo
hoy estoy aquí
para que hablemos no de como crear una
obra sino de como
volvernos seres creativos lo importante
aquí no va a ser el resultado va a ser
cómo nos vamos transformando y como la
mirada nos va cambiando
están listas están listos
muy bien para comenzar vamos a hacer una
travesía por las fuentes de la
creatividad y digo travesía porque esta
aventura necesita coraje y perseverancia
quiero preguntarles para comenzar esta
travesía quién les parece más creativo
el rebelde pablo picasso con más de 28
mil obras catalogadas y cuatro mil
quinientos treinta pinturas
steve jobs el genio de nuestra época que
transformó la manera como nos
relacionamos con la tecnología
o quizá alguien menos conocida
jane goodall una primatóloga inglesa que
generó una revolución ambiental que ha
involucrado a más de 10.000 grupos de
jóvenes en 140 países
cuando nos observamos
si miramos más de cerca cada uno bebió
de fuentes de creatividad distintas
hace 12 años comenzó mi pasión por la
creatividad me preguntaba qué es esa
fuerza que me inspira a crear qué
condiciones favorecen el ser creativo es
posible aprender y enseñar la
creatividad
he buscado en los libros seguido a los
referentes entrevistado creadores
incorporado técnicas en mi vida pero
sobre todo he recreado mi existencia en
tres oportunidades y en esta aventura
personal he descubierto que la
creatividad bebé de tres fuentes el
instinto la lucidez y la intuición
el instituto
es el lugar donde habitan los impulsos
primordiales donde tenemos una inmensa
capacidad por la libertad una pasión un
fuego que no conoce ataduras como diría
la investigadora del en winner se trata
de una furia por dominar
la lucidez
es la fuente donde lo desconectado se
une
donde aparece un juego asociativo que
quiere generar originalidad es allí
donde los problemas nos entusiasman y
que generan nuevas rutas
y la intuición es como un jardín secreto
un jardín secreto donde tenemos una
visión a la vez íntima y abarcadora la
intuición sólo aparece cuando se acalla
la mente y la tendencia a la que nos
invita
es al cuidado
y a la unión
instinto lucidez intuición esas son las
fuentes de la creatividad pero para
atraparlas para hacerlas necesitamos ser
cuidadosos porque
el instinto por sí solo puede llevarnos
al deseo sin control la lucidez por sí
sola puede despertar arrogancia y la
intuición por sí sola puede ser utópica
por eso necesitamos la ayuda de tres
fuerzas tres personajes que nos van a
ayudar a navegar por estas fuentes de la
creatividad el artista el innovador y el
visionario ellos nos van a permitir
atrapar el universo y hacerlo fluir a
través de nuestros ojos como dijo el
filósofo peter cost embone
miremos de cerca
a estos personajes
el artista es capaz de beber del
instinto y hacerlo
fluir tiene una gran amistad con el niño
por eso sabe jugar expresa con libertad
y sobre todo
es capaz de sentir los ritmos de la
naturaleza sus secretos son dos la
atención y la belleza
así ya
nueve años descubrí a mi artista
nací en una ciudad gris a 2600 metros y
donde llueve más de 200 días al año
tenía 28 años un poco más de pelo y a
los ojos de la sociedad
estaba siguiendo el camino correcto
era profesor universitario emprendedor
editaba revistas pero a medida que
llenaba las casillas de logro sentía
que mi ansiedad subía y mi creatividad
se secaba entonces dio un gran paso
viaje al caribe a tomar un retiro de un
año
para meditar relajarme y tener quietud y
el primer día me guía en el proceso me
dijo cada día vas a escribir un poema
al comienzo
tomé la tarea con despreocupación
luego hice
fallidos intentos de arrogancia para
querer sobresalir y fue entonces cuando
mi guía me dijo tiende en el suelo y
espera a que las cosas te hablen
me moví lento
permitirá quietud y entonces apareció lo
simple
escribí escribí escribí y no pare de
escribir no eran grandes poemas pero
este proceso de detenerme
escuchar
observar y dejar ir produjo en mí una
sanación creativa
las manchas del gato
el color de los mangos maduros la hierba
que se resistía entre las losas
una hilera de hormigas
cosa del mundo me empezó a mostrar un
brillo inusitado
durante ese año
medite
conocía un poco más de mí pero fue en el
encuentro con el artista donde descubrí
el deleite de fluir
bueno basta de hablar de mí vámonos a
nuestro segundo personaje alguien se
acuerda quién era
muy bien estaban dormidos muy bien el
innovador gracias el innovador el
innovador
es distinto obviamente al artista porque
el innovador toma las conexiones de la
lucidez las integra y las aplica a la
vida por eso el innovador es pragmático
piensa con diferentes sombreros el
innovador en los problemas trampolines y
sobre todo abraza el fracaso sigue el
proverbio japonés que dice si te caes
siete veces te levantas ocho
y los dos secretos de este innovador son
la integración y el cambio
hoy creemos que los innovadores son
aquellos que proponen soluciones
tecnológicas o emprendimientos exitosos
pero en nuestra vida cotidiana nos
conectamos con nuestro innovador todo el
tiempo cuando enfrentamos un desafío y
luego de choque emocional nos abrimos a
la experiencia nos hacemos flexibles y
tomamos distintas rutas nuestro
innovador nos lleva a romper los hábitos
nos lleva a salir de los gustos y
disgustos a permitirnos la exploración
y así queridos amigos y amigos hemos
llegado a nuestro tercer protagonista
cuál es
el visionario este me gusta mucho porque
es capaz
de beber en la intuición conoce la
quietud la contemplación como decía un
poeta norteamericano theodore rod qué
una mente demasiado activa no es mente
por eso el visionario se detiene escucha
cultiva la humildad emprende grandes
desafíos cuida de otros y el mundo
este visionario
tiene dos secretos
el cuidado y la virtud como lo entendía
aristóteles como la voluntad y la
habilidad de hacer el bien
artista
innovador
y visionario
ellos hacen parte de las fuentes de la
creatividad y nos llevan a ser seres
creativos integrales seguramente
crearemos en un solo ámbito pero el
artista nos enseñará a ir a nuestras
profundidades el innovador nos dará
mirada amplia y el visionario
nos enseñará
la elevación
estos personajes y las fuentes de la
creatividad me han acompañado en los
últimos nueve años
mi artista conoció el amor por lo sutil
durante tres años que vivía en la selva
innovador se abrió la experiencia de
crear una nueva vida en la tierra del
mate las acequias y la montaña
y mi inspirador innovador mi artista se
han unido en mi visionario que se siente
profundamente conmovido al ver
movimientos como este y como muchos más
que están haciendo de mendoza un mejor
lugar para vivir
ahora tengo un sueño pequeño
que cada uno de ustedes empiece a
visitar sus fuentes de la creatividad
despierte sus personajes se permitan el
silencio
y luego se enfrenten a la vida
creativamente para hacerlo quiero que me
acompañen a responder tres preguntas que
las pasen por su cuerpo que se permitan
el silencio
que las respondan en sus mentes y las
manifiesten en sus vidas
crucen sus manos de esta manera por
favor
observen las
sientan la leve presión
y mientras las van separando
respondan en sus mentes a la siguiente
pregunta
qué pequeña expresión puedo hacer
para liberar a mi artista
ahora lleve en sus manos al lado de sus
ojos cierren la mirada
siento en el confort
y ahora lentamente abran las mientras
responden que pequeña acción puedo hacer
para darle poder a mi innovador
y finalmente pongan sus manos junto a su
pecho y mientras bajan la cabeza para
observarla
respondan
qué pequeño paso puedo hacer para servir
más al mundo
gracias
[Aplausos]